oh I'm super upset yeah because you're
like a terrible parent don't I don't
know I would never jack off another dude
I will say out that yeah Yoshi Yoshi
Yoshi was our young man I really need
someone well here's a Tesla so that's
like us modelling do skin stress
watch this [ __ ] though this is this is
the true question alright I asked this
to everybody and everybody has a price
what is the lowest $2 oh wow okay what
is what is the lowest amount of money
that you'll take to suck a dick damn
unless you've not to completion just
like Oh a little bit I'll call the five
five swipes Gorgon style like that
you got a cradle balls to like that you
got a grab ball you know honestly I'm
afraid to say this but it's uh pride not
that expensive boys that number dunno I
really don't know how thousand dollars
no I wouldn't do for a thousand five
thousand dollars mm probably not how
hard is your life right now
alright what's going on depends on what
state I'm in you know five hundred
dollars and I'd be like hey will you pay
for the wedding
okay cool if some guy was like I'll pay
for your wedding but you just have to
like your father's like like all the way
to the back of the throat five times
like my dad
you also gets to grab your head in the
back because I have to hear skin to
forehead contact yeah yeah yeah I don't
know watch your nose on my bellybutton
here's the thing I don't know about that
because I don't know if my I'm not that
confident in my abilities to do that cuz
I never tried it thirty thousand dollars
the fact that you have to think about it
shows your trash dude nah man is way too
low you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] what's
wrong with you it's for comedic effect
right the comedic effect my ass did or
the other guy's ass you [ __ ] weird
there's that here's a question I always
ask if gun your head but actually no no
gun your head you have to pick would you
rather get like plowed in the butt this
is a vision ask at church and yeah to my
mom my sister is everybody clients
clients a mob real quick serious
question cloud the ass
or finish the dude off by you know
sucking him off to completion Jesus I
would definitely suck the dude's dick oh
dude no man what would you do no they're
both pretty rough why don't you explain
your reasoning why that's such I feel I
feel like a [ __ ] is way more like
yeah but a [ __ ]
you're in control the other one you're
getting [ __ ] in the ass you have to if
you can't do completion if you go to
completion why is why is one way if the
guy completely ass they're both yes
completing and - is he coming in my ass
is a question uh what did you want he's
not completing in my mouth and exactly
that's the thing it's like I would never
I would never put a you suck a dick
you're in control though the other one
the guys grabbing your hips and lifting
you in the air is your little tiny ass
hey dude he's [ __ ] the living [ __ ] I
mean they were strong because I strength
trained pretty frequently so I think I
could finish him off pretty quick second
I feel like putting a penis your mouth
is way more intimate and I'm not really
about that but you could but see here's
the thing though cuz there you could
easily versus you have to like taste
that's weird
honey I would just eat a bunch of ice
cubes and I would that [ __ ] out you
didn't tell me how I have to do it and
on top of that I would make him shower
thoroughly now you can take you just
beat us you can't get easy and what age
whatever you want
choose your own adventure at this point
it's choose my home
it's swiping through dick oh yeah this
one I'll go with this so you would
rather get what about you he won't pick
I asked is so hard to actually think
about that
yeah you have to answer it um there is
no bush so you'd say you'd finish a dude
off by second Ahmad but I think when you
think about how much work when I
actually think about it I just it's like
so horrific for me that I like both are
her lame dude you're still aiming I'm
gonna pick I'm gonna pick I think he's
not gonna fake my parents are so proud
of us right now the skinny Valley
everyone everyone in the comments is
gonna be - they would all right all the
comments have to [ __ ] if you're
enough to answer if you're a hetero male
you have to answer what are we doing
here if you're not mm-hmm answer it I
think I would go with suck I think it's
suck a dick dude really you know why
because he's a [ __ ] man and you're a
little [ __ ] that's why you would get
[ __ ] in the butt dude he would be like
going hard on your ass I'm talking about
he would grab your hip bones yeah and
just I'm looking over there like he
would [ __ ] you so hard from the back
your eyes will pop out like a acne
cartoon yeah you'd be like slow down do
I shut the [ __ ] now what's your [ __ ]
dick sucking price now it's I don't know
man I'm not really down five hundred
thousand for five pumps five pumps no I
please just heads back of the head I
feel like that's not asking a lot so is
that a yes you would do it for 500,000
realistically yeah realistically man I
think I might think I'm gonna think
about it I'll take a day 600,000 that's
we're here already I would say let's
just go for the mill but I don't think
I'm you know like I'm not making that
you're not making the conditions hola
vez hola the the angry Russian
he's Russian man he's my wife seven
hundred and fifty thousand dollars I
probably I'm definitely leaning towards
yes the only reason why I'm asking is I
wanted to say this now you're [ __ ]
gay
I did it's a spectrum bro and I knew it
you should have came out the closet
750,000 s [ __ ] low dude is it I don't
know man Patrick was foreknown tax free
talking tax we're going to tax rate in a
suitcase sick sequential sequential
sequential completion sequential damn
bro I don't have a million million
dollars then 1 million more untaxed see
the thing is is like it sound like like
even like 10 million dollars dude 5 be
like yeah so much money you set my life
but then actually getting into the room
and the guy banging all right here we go
and you like guns if it's a dick out
it's like follow five months is not
hello hello I pumped that's not that
much but made nutshell a little quite
while but needs 5 pumps for 2 million
[Laughter]
I respect Patrick way more than you
because he got second no I said a
billion he was like are you [ __ ]
kidding me you I said five hundred
thousand you went Wow 90 bucks you piece
of [ __ ] hey man this is this is who we
are baby 750 K that's not bad that's not
bad nah dude for five cuz every time
you'd spend that money you would not
like every bill like you'd have that
money for a while and you'd be like damn
I see that was him self respect for this
for this despite express million dollars
no dude I don't think so
forty million it would have to be the
only way that I would consider it is if
it was like you literally never have to
work like you won't have money for the
rest of your life and never have to work
again that's the only way I would like
Ted you're a [ __ ] prude ten million
dollars dude that's you'll never let's
let's make fun of Patrick about what a
Prudy is am i right yeah this guy is the
[ __ ] no one dude you guys are like on
the opposite spectrum because you know
cell precision is too much self-respect
tiffany tiffany would be mad at me
and that's crazy how much would it take
you how much money o me a solid 12 cents
I think it would be a good like if I
wasn't being realistic really would
change my life
yeah first of all I already asked Muriel
if it's okay and she said no but she's
just so [ __ ] dumb because it was
change our whole lives because he's not
even coming in my face or anything dude
it's just five level of this super fast
five pumps they obviously need a
popsicle that [ __ ] disappears like that
yeah I would do it for easy eight
million because I think eight million
can changed my life and I don't have to
work well you have a great big social
media following - so that's that's a
good thing if it is supported and people
had to see the video
easy it has to be like 20 million cuz
then I could live with that shame right
I'll be living in that [ __ ] for
traveling if somebody if somebody saw
saw that I would go way up more than
that if it was on the way 900,000 you
traveling to your grave millions - more
can't $2,000 more and then you're gonna
upload it and put it on the hub whoo
damn come on man you walk in that you
walk into a coffee shop man ones like
this guy has no value to himself as a
human being yeah if nobody sought I'll
do Oh every everybody sees this video
now what's your price oh dude I'm
talking easy no 100 ml hundred mil damn
really yeah what from [ __ ] 750,000
well no now you're just this is behind
closed doors I'll do it for 40 bucks in
dollars so high here trying to save face
so bad he's like and the other one the
750,000 was was to completion there was
not to completion yeah the first one was
for completion now you're making [ __ ] up
oh I'm [ __ ] we never say completion this
was literally said no easy
a million now oh now that you guys are
changing your life yes he did so his
number would be a hundred million
because he has a lot of self-respect
also clearly he doesn't care about his
daughter
honestly like hey your dad's a
[ __ ] you like the wrong reason
baby it's like dad did you really suck
dick yeah do you have clothes on your
back you stupid little [ __ ] like this
mansion yeah yeah you know what these
lips daddy suck dick for this mansion
[ __ ] start selling just like daddy
suck dick for this mansion yeah you just
you would have to own it you'd have to
like you can't you can't ever like
Charlie Sheen a mess-up dick for money
if everybody knew then yeah you you have
to go higher but if nobody knew it's
different it's very different but then
every time anyone mentioned anything
about like sucking dick you'd be like
you just begin to be in the corner like
blah blah it'd be really awkward yes so
but if you're a body like all weird if
you're a I thing with my personality
type I'd be completely okay with it I
would be okay with people clowning on me
for the rest of my life if I had 40
million dollars in the bank yeah hundred
fifty k sounds not that much if you say
40 and you know we're in this world now
where it's all about fluidity and LGBTQA
VT yeah yeah so I'm pretty sure that I
would have a huge amount of support
saying you know what dude your flute
your flu ID yeah you're socialized [ __ ]
man that's really progressive of you and
I'm you've come a long way dude so thank
you I still can't believe you're number
seven hundred fifty thousand dollars
that's actually the lowest out of I've
asked a lot of people well all your rich
time actually I'm not rich I once I
think even say seven hundred thousand he
said a cool two million so you're really
below oh that guy sleeps outside of my
house so I know a real good friend
yeah and he's ashamed of you dude no Dan
I think Tiffany would be like just
you're not worth more than a millstone
just go 750 K don't be like yeah you
should marry her do she sounds great
yeah okay is my final answer for now cuz
money can really change your life though
like I I don't
it's weird I don't think I go around
life thinking too much about money but I
think as I get I'm getting all
I am thinking about money now it's like
oh [ __ ] like I mean for you you have a
kid I think about if I have a kid what
if I need to get a house and also the
[ __ ] so I freak out a little bit now I'm
like well [ __ ] like maybe money is
important when it's not just you sure
and then I have a I have a fiance now so
I'm like oh what the [ __ ] I guess I
should really think about making money
now yeah yeah no it's stressful this
dressed as me especially like having a
daughter I'm like [ __ ] dude like I got a
food I mean I wanted to live good you
know like yeah it is it does put a huge
weight on you can I just say the
transition from how what we were talking
about before so where it's at now is
just like a really cool transition thank
you we're talking about sucking dick for
money and then how important money is
that is that is that is important that
is the price that we need to pay for our
future children
yeah you're right cuz I don't think my
kids would mind no honestly if you
really did get 40 million for sucking
some dick I don't think your kids in
mind either they probably would